hello and thank you for joining us uh
welcome to the second
richard m carp distinguished lecture
this semester
uh my name is peter bartlett i'm the
associate director of the simons
institute for the theory of computing
we established the rmk series to
celebrate the pioneering role
of summer's institute founding director
dick carp in theoretical computer
science
formerly these were known as the simon's
institute open lectures
they feature visionary leaders in the
field of theoretical computer science on
topics associated with current programs
running at the simons institute and the
series is geared towards a broad
scientific audience
we're grateful to the many contributors
to the richard m carp fund
who've made this series possible so this
semester the simon's institute's hosting
two programs
one on probability geometry and
computation in high dimensions
and one on the theory of reinforcement
learning and i'm delighted to welcome
our speaker today
professor claire tomlin who's
participating in the reinforcement
learning program
claire is professor of electrical
engineering and computer science and
holder of the charles a desolate chair
in engineering here at uc berkeley she
received her phd from berkeley and was a
professor at stanford for
seven years before returning to berkeley
as a professor in
2005. claire is famous for her work in
hybrid systems and control
in safe learning methods that combine
tools from machine learning and control
theory and in applications in air
traffic control and unmanned aerial
vehicles
she's been honoured with the donald p
eckman award the
ieee transportation technologies award
and an honorary doctorate from
kth the royal institute of technology in
sweden
and claire is also a macarthur
foundation fellow an ieee fellow
a fellow of the american institute for
medical and biological engineering
and a member of the national academy of
engineering and the american academy of
arts and sciences
so delighted to have claire talking
today her talk is titled
safe learning in robotics welcome claire
thank you thank you very much peter for
the invitation and thank you to the
simon's institute
um it is an honor and a pleasure
to give this talk especially this talk
named for
my colleague professor richard carp
today i'd like to talk about safe
learning in robotics
and i'd like to bring a control
theoretic
viewpoint to the
problem of learning
in large-scale systems where there's a
lot of
new data available for use yet the
dynamics and the constraints
and the safety criticality of the
problems are very important
all right let me just see how this is
not advancing
good uh so as i said i'd like to start
um by talking about some of these
large-scale systems and for
um throughout my career in fact since i
was a phd student
i've been working quite closely with
engineers scientists and developers at
nasa ames
who have been interested in developing
new tools models and methods
for doing air traffic control and
this is a wonderful problem i'm just
showing um a snapshot of some of the
data across aircraft across the united
states and then on
the bottom left a movie showing a few
hours of aircraft coming into and going
out of the
the bay area airports so this is a
system
in air traffic control where there
there is a lot of new data available
data about
routes about weather about other
aircraft in the system
there's also um new emerging
applications which are
which is making the air traffic system a
lot more interesting
the use of small aircraft air taxis and
what i've pictured here
are the potential uses of delivery
drones which have to fly through the air
traffic system
and in all of this safety is critical
but it's a system where there's
a share of control between
what will be automated or what is
automated now
and the humans the people who are
involved in the control
so there's um maybe simplicity is the
wrong word but there's a sense
that um the system has to be
understandable any automation that's
being performed has to be understandable
by the people in the loop
and and learning using modern
ai and machine learning tools makes a
lot of sense in the system because there
as i said there's a lot of data
about these systems real time data that
can be collected
and and so it's exciting to think of
adaptation
so how one might adapt to the current
control methods or a current control
policy
as new data comes in and so we've been
working for years as i said with nasa
and we've just started a a new project
with nasa
trying to investigate how machine
learning can be used in this next
generation air traffic system
and um you know these are just two
companies um in the bay area
that have been hiring some of the
students from our
our research groups who um these are
vehicles on the left is a
an air vehicle on the right is a a
delivery vehicle
um that is an automated vehicle so
there's not
there's no people in in the in either of
these vehicles
but they're systems that are um um
in a sense they're as close to fully
autonomous as we can imagine
using their sensors on board they
perceive the world
and they react and interact and
importantly
they react and interact to environments
where
um you know there's a lot that's known
about the environments that they're
um that they're operating in but there's
also a lot that's unknown
especially the around the people that
are interacting in the environment with
these vehicles
um so here's another example of safety
critical vehicles where
we're very interested in understanding
how to incorporate
machine learning tools so today's talk
has two pieces the first piece i'm going
to introduce
a tool that we've been developing for
now
well the past couple of decades we've
been building on in my research group
which is a method for um
respecting constraints within a control
system
how you verify that a control system
respects those constraints and how do
you design control systems such that
constraints are respected
and that's a tool called reachability
it's an old idea
and we have built on that idea and built
a toolbox or a number of toolboxes of
methods to
verify and design controllers and for
the second part of the talk
i'm going to incorporate machine
learning
into this methodology and show steps of
how
one might approach incorporating such
data-driven methods into such a
a safe control structure
so let's start with a a kind of
conceptual diagram
and here i've pictured and i'm going to
use my
mouse and i've forgot to check this but
can people see that i'm my my little
mouse on the screen
right now i'm circling the differential
equation x dot is equal to f of x ud
yeah we can see that okay great so this
is um
this is a diagram it's sort of a again a
stylized picture suppose that
you know this uh this slide represents
my state space
x for example and i have some dynamic
system that's evolving let's just
suppose it's
governed by a differential equation um x
dot is equal to f of x u
and um so you might be
uh the control inputs the that one um
either the
you know the person that's interacting
with the system or
um the automation can manipulate and
then we also allow for some disturbances
d
in the system that we can't control but
we assume that we know some bounds on
those disturbances
suppose one has a sense of what it means
for this system to be
safe or unsafe and suppose that that
safety or unsafety can be represented
as remaining either within or outside
a subset of the state space of the
system
and this is the set here that we label
the set g
at time zero that that red ellipse that
i'm showing
so the um the backwards reachable set
which is shown here in pink so the
backwards reachable set for a particular
time horizon t which we'll call g of t
is that set of all possible states
for which for all possible control
actions
u there exists a disturbance which could
drive the system into that unsafe set
in t within t time units so that means
that
if we call um suppose in a you know in a
control system where we're interested
for example
in collision avoidance so that's one of
the first problems
example problems that i'll show you so
collision
uh you know in the air traffic system
means that any pair of aircraft
comes closer than a certain requisite
distance
so that's some separation loss of
separation
so we can represent collision as some
subset of the system state space and
then
this um this red region this backwards
reachable set
could then encode all states for which
despite the best possible actions of the
aircraft the maneuvers that they can
make
the dynamics of the system coupled with
unknown disturbances
could drive the system to unsafety
so the point is that if this set g of
zero represents an unsafe set
then this backwards reachable set
represents states
for which you you want to make sure you
avoid because if you get into those
states
it's um and you know the the disturbance
for example
does do its worst possible action the
system could go to unsafety
so i i sort of used a terminology that
makes us think about a game
the the best possible control actions
for the worst possible disturbance under
these dynamics
and in fact we use game theory to
compute or to characterize and then
compute these reachable sets
it's like we're we're pitting the
control against the disturbance as
players in a game
and we pose the problem as a game the
best possible actions of one player are
not sufficient to protect against the
worst possible actions of the other
so we're going to label that state as
unsafe
and and so that set itself is
interesting
and that's something we're after to
compute because if we could compute that
then we could um ensure that if we stay
outside
of that set so in this blue region here
that will keep the system
outside of the unsafe region for at
least
t time units all right so that's the
value of
of a backwards reachable set and that
kind of describes in words what it is
we've worked on developing a theory for
computing that those reachable sets and
we've shown
that and us and others have shown
that that backwards reachable set can be
expressed
implicitly as the subzero level sets
of some value function j of x t where j
of x
t is the solution to this
um what is called a hamilton jacobi um
either bellman or isaac's equation we
usually call this a hamilton jacobi
isaac's equation because rufus isaacs is
responsible
for some of the original work and
dynamic game theory
and when we're using this combination of
control and disturbance as two players
we're posing it as a game
it's um it's a little bit different than
a standard
hamilton jacobi pde because we have this
uh
we have this min with zero on the right
hand side
and that's important for reachability it
basically ensures that once the state
has been labeled as unsafe it doesn't
become safe
at a at a future time so you can't for
example
start out as a at a state and over the
time horizon go
through the unsafe set and come out the
other side and therefore label that
state as safe
because at the end of the time horizon
it's outside of the set you don't want
states to trajectories from states to
even go through that set
and that min with zero ensures that
um that you're you're computing the full
reachable set
okay so the idea then is um well
the idea that we asked is could we
compute this set via some kind of
um bellman iteration process applied to
this hamilton jacobi equation
and and really you know sort of um maybe
diagrammatically with this stylized
diagram
what we're doing is we're we're taking
the you know the states on the boundary
of that set
at each iteration and we're asking are
they safe for the next epsilon time
units and if not we propagate the
boundary of the set
backwards and so if we had a vector
field here
that's um in general pointing to the
left of the screen then the backwards
reachable set would propagate backwards
to the right
okay so that's the general idea we have
we have a way to characterize the set
implicitly through a value function and
we also
have a way to describe
the you know the equation that we need
to solve to compute it
now the challenge is computing it um
and so uh so we've we've uh
from the beginning we started using
level set methods which were developed
um by stan osher and jamie sethian
um and john um in in sort of different
groups
and um and and so the idea and here i've
pictured it
from a side view is that that set
if we characterize that set as the
subzero level sets of a function
then at the bottom i've shown what you
know a slice of that function might look
like
and so initially we have a set here
here's the slice of that set whose
sub-zero level sets represent that
ellipse
and then over time we're taking that
function j of x
t and we're evolving it according to the
hamilton jacobi
isaac's equation so we're maintaining
the sub-zero level sets of the evolution
of j
okay so a few points here that i'm going
to come up again later when we when we
introduce
machine learning so if the set is
controlled invariant for all t that
means that
if after some you know finite time
horizon
that set or you know whatever that time
horizon is that set closes off and it
doesn't grow anymore
then any super zero level set of that
function
is also invariant and may be used to
prove safety of a control system
so that's kind of intuitive if you can
stay outside
of the a super zero level set so if you
can stay outside of a set
that is guaranteed to contain the set
then you're staying outside of the set
itself
if that set does represent an unsafe set
um and then the other thing
is that even if the disturbance were
known there still might be some volume
in that set right just coming from the
dynamics
you can imagine if you're riding a
bicycle towards you know there's a tree
in front of you
then you know despite like the maximum
control effort
turning to the left or turning to the
right if you're too close to the tree
you're still gonna hit it
right so so but if the disturbance is
known
then we could theoretically compute the
optimal reachable set the smallest
unsafe set for example
that just is a result of the dynamics
itself
um okay so in terms of computing them
that as i said is a big problem um and
that's been a challenge that we've been
working on in my group and other groups
for a long time
we um we as i said used the
concept of level set methods which
generally are methods to compute
solutions to pdes
you know governing before we started
working on it most of the methods have
been applied to
equations which govern one fluid flow
through another material for example so
we applied this to control systems
and um and so here you can see one of
our our control system examples it's
sort of an interesting
uh shape here but it's um you know the
final
function looks like this over part of
the domain and we're capturing the sub
zero level sets of that function
um what's interesting about this well
the boundary
of the region the boundary of that set
is defined implicitly
by the zero level set of that function
and then anywhere away from that
function so if we're using
if if we use a sine distance function
for j for example
then the magnitude of j at any point
is the distance from that state x to the
boundary
whether you're inside or outside so if
you're inside
j is negative and outside j is positive
and this is all interesting information
for control
because often you know we don't only
want to know
you know whether we're at the boundary
and we have to apply a safe control to
stay out
but we want to know whether you know how
far we are away from the boundary
okay so at the bottom i've provided two
links these are references um ian
mitchell was my first phd student
at stanford he's now a professor of
computer science at the university of
british columbia in vancouver
and um and we worked on the theory of
this together
and then when he became an assistant
professor he coded up
what he calls toolbox ls so this is a
level set toolbox
for doing some of these computations for
a number of different control
um continuous control and hybrid system
examples
and it's well documented you can
download the toolbox it's written
in um largely in matlab and it's got a
graphical
interface in matlab um and since then
we've been working with a number of my
my students in particular mo chen who's
now a professor at
simon fraser university also in
vancouver and
um sylvia herbert who's just finishing
her phd this year and is going off to uc
san diego to be an assistant
professor and others to develop
a c plus implementation of the level set
toolbox as well as a bunch of useful
kind of wrappers
um to um to enable you know the
to to do like sort of an easy um
interface with
uh the level set toolbox and i've
provided um a link to that
uh the uh the c plus plus implementation
of the level set code there
okay so here's one example this is what
i was maybe some of you recognize this
is a field at stanford so this is when i
was still at stanford but i like this
example
there are some there's four rotors um we
this was back before you could buy
quadrotors on every
street corner and we um we built these
ourselves
uh with the you know onboard computers
and carbon
fiber tubes and um there are four
students there
and each is uh controlling via a
joystick
a single quadrotor however when the
quadrotors get
closer than their reachable set distance
and on the right i've got a snapshot
of each quad rotor with the reachable
set for collision
for that aircraft that quadrotor with
the each of the other three aircraft
around it so when one quadrotor comes
within
the safety distance the reachable set
diff distance
of another quadrotor the onboard control
takes over and guides the vehicle away
from each other
and what's that control it's simply that
max over you
from the hamilton jacobi equation which
not only gives you the reachable set but
it gives you the best control to use
at the boundary of the reachable set to
ensure
that the vehicles don't lose separation
and so the the the automation takes over
guides the vehicle away from each from
the vehicle that it's um potentially in
collision with
and then after a little bit the control
is passed back to the
human the student who's joysticking the
vehicle around which isn't the best
interface but it's
more of a a test of implementation of
this method
and we tried this was kind of fun
because the students were trying to
you know they're trying to cause
collision and basically this
reachable set acts like a an invisible
field that keeps the vehicles away from
each other
i like this example even after so many
years i think it's quite illustrative of
the method
and the fact that we can run this in
real time
uh if you can do set avoidance you can
also do set capture you just
change the role of the min and the max
so now you'd like to
reach a desired set uh despite you know
disturbances which may be pushing you
away from that set so we call that a
capture
basin that we want to compute the
backwards reachable set
is the capture basin it describes
um the set of states for which there
exists a control that you can get to
that desired so you can get to that
desired region
while um despite disturbances that may
be trying to push you away
it's a hamilton jacobi bellman equation
the only difference is that the min
and the max roll have been have been
flipped
and you can piece these together so not
only um
can you uh uh so you can piece these
together in a couple of ways
first of all you can compute reach avoid
sets
so sets of states which reach a target
set
while avoiding an unsafe region while
maintaining constraints
and then you can think about a hybrid
system where you're switching between
different
modes maybe different dynamic behavior
which we use a lot in
aircraft control for example when we're
switching between
a um you know a capture altitude mode
or a landing mode or in collision
avoidance when you're switching between
uh you know a regular following path
mode versus avoiding
another aircraft um and so here we've
got
uh two different um flight modes and
we've got
we can string this together so we'd like
to end up in a target set
and so we compute first of all
the the capture basin for the capture
basin
for the ultimate target set so in that
way we can kind of back
chain these reachable sets all the while
avoiding unsafe
sets and what's nice is when you define
these sets
implicitly in terms of these these you
know functions
j of x t so the function's in one higher
dimension
the computation becomes quite uh
intuitive
i mean it's still a hamilton jacobi
equation we still have to deal with the
curse of dimensionality which i'm going
to talk about for a few minutes
but but things like um reaching one set
while avoiding another
is just in those sets it can just be
computed like a mask
you you compute one set and then you
mask out another set
and that becomes um a constraint that
i'm showing here
like subject to for some reason
everybody maybe can see my mouse except
for me
but um but we set up what's called a
variational inequality
where we're computing the solution to
that pde
subject to the constraints of avoiding
the unsafe set
okay so dealing with the curse of
dimensionality this has been a big
direction in my research group i would
say
you know in in terms of our research now
um and working in reachability and
uh safe learning um probably about half
of the work
is in trying to um trying to do
computations like this efficiently in
high dimensions
and then half of the work is in methods
to
incorporate machine learning for data
driven so for systems where
you only know part of the model or you
only know part of the environment
and you want to learn that as you go um
so and it's you know there's a lot
there's quite a big community working in
these types of tools
and i've listed um just some of the work
that's been doing and
people have been approaching
the problem of cursive dimensionality in
many different ways sometimes very
practical ways like
if you have a bunch of vehicles on the
road
you know that's a very high dimensional
problem if you think about the
multi-agent collision avoidance problem
so impose some practical constraints
you know you put roadways in this in the
air traffic system
there are highways in the sky so that
the vehicles are lined up against each
other
and you really only have to consider
constraints with respect to the vehicles
that are closest to you
a lot of work in approximating or over
approximating reachable sets
um by approximating the sets
approximating the dynamics
and using simpler representations of
sets and dynamics than just say a level
set function of a complicated hamilton
jacobi equation
methods that we've also contributed to
on decompositions how might you
take a high dimensional system and
decompose it into a bunch of low
dimensional systems
compute the reachable set in the low
dimensional system
and then use that to compute either an
exact or over
approximate representation of the
reachable set in the in the high
dimension
and i'm going to briefly mention the
last two projects that we have because
they're quite recent projects on the
last two points uh this morning
one is how might you exploit offline
computation you know if you could
compute a reachable set offline
and use it online that's a promising
method
and then the second is something that
really has been over the past few months
we've actually been trying to use
machine learning to compute
solutions to these hamilton jacobi
equations and i i just want to mention
that very briefly
i think it's it's quite exciting
so so this um this set of examples comes
from
the phd work of mo chen and sylvia
herbert
and and and several others actually i'll
reference some
i'll reference the others but the idea
here is that if we could
um in the and i'm using the context of
now robot
path planning well robot or autonomous
vehicle path planning um
and suppose that we um we had this
reachable
set tool but we couldn't compute it in
real time because
our dynamics were you know perhaps they
were high dimensional like the quad
rotor over on the left
but we have access to fast robot path
planning methods for low dimensional
models
and that's what i'm showing on the right
in this fast but accurate
fast but less accurate planning less
accurate because we're using low
dimensional models
but if we try to use high dimensional
models we would have a very slow but
you know accurate planning so our
proposal in terms of reachability
is to use the the model error the
difference between
the high dimensional model of the
aircraft
and the low dimensional model of the
aircraft compute a model error
and then compute reachability based on
that model error compute a tracking
error bound
how far can the high dimensional model
be
away from the low dimensional model and
if we've pre-computed that
then we can carry that precomputation
around us while doing fast planning
because it gives us a principled error
bound around our low dimensional
planning model
which will ensure that if we compute a
plan using the low dimensional model
the high dimensional model will always
be able to track it
and what's more stay within the
reachability constraints
so i've described what the method is
very briefly and i have an animation
that describes it
so the idea is we have a two these two
systems i'll call them planning and
tracking system
and we'd like to be able to compute
say over this particular value function
which i've i've shown on the right
the the set which is so
the the bound between those two models
which translates to the largest
controlled invariant set within
that value function which is described
by
the distance between the two models so
what this diagram shows is a
reachability computation
and so let me just say it more
concretely what i said in a fairly
abstract way
that if for example you would like
your planning model to stay within 0.5
meters of your tracking model
so that was the smallest set there's no
control given the models that we have in
this particular example
that will let you that will let you do
that namely there's no way with the
models that we have that you can
guarantee a 0.5 meter tracking error
down
but if you increase that to 0.75 meters
there is actually some volume in that
reachable set this purple region here
that's the region that describes those
states which are guaranteed to stay
within 0.75 meters of the fast planning
model
and if you increase that bound to
one meter then there's an even larger
controlled invariant set
okay that's described on the right here
and so that's the reachability
computation that's how we compute the
tracking error bound and we determine
what you know these these minimum
tracking error bounds can be
when we're doing robot path planning in
real time
so we've applied this you know this is
just a simulation showing
a 10 d 10 dimensional near hover
quadrotor
model this is a good model of a
quadrotor if it's sort of a near hover
condition
and it's tracking a planning model which
is a 3d point source so we can do very
fast
planning using that so this is using um
rrt method which is a fast um a
a very ubiquitous method used in
robot path planning okay so here
um the vehicle is the uh so the
the the green star is the planning model
the
box around that in three dimensions
is a three-dimensional projection of the
ten-dimensional reachable set
into the three dimensions of xyz and
that planning model is trying to get to
the goal on the right hand side and it's
being faced in real time
with constraints that it detects when
it's within a sensing down
um so that box around it describes
the tracking error bound it says that
that 10d model
is always guaranteed to be within that
um that box around the planning model
and so we can use that box for planning
in real time because we've done that
pre-computation
okay so we've tried this in a number of
um
a number of more complex scenarios we've
used it
um to switch you know we've said well
you're never gonna get
um with this simple planning model
you're never going to be able to
meet the meet the small tracking error
bounds you need maybe to go through
narrow corridors
so that gives us an indication of well
how about if we then
switch to a different planning model
which is higher dimensional
but it gives us a smaller tracking error
bound with the full dimensional tracking
model
and so not only can reachability compute
these tracking error bounds
but it can tell you exactly where you
should switch
to a higher dimensional planning model
so that you can meet the constraints of
the planning problem
and um and what what's the cost of that
it just means that the planning becomes
slower because you're using a high
dimensional model
so it's like this planning fast and slow
when you're in wide open spaces you can
move quickly with a big tracking error
bound
as you get into smaller corridors you
slow down because you need a smaller
tracking error
bound and you can pre-compute these
ahead of time
so this is the work of david fridovich
kyle and sylvia herbert and others
which we published in icra a couple
years ago
others have used this so we've we've
teamed up with alan yang
um and uh some researchers from sean
carsastri's group
who have been using this uh this method
of fast um of
fast planning and like computing a
tracking airbound so we can do fast and
safe planning
uh in their augmented and virtual
reality systems
and the idea um and i don't think i have
time to show this video because i want
to get onto the learning
is that um you know the the user the
person who's setting out the plan can
just put a rough sequence of waypoints
out
in the space and then in the um in the
lab behind him as a quadrotor that's
flying the trajectory set out by those
waypoints
using this fast planning method
in real time we call this method fast
track for
fast and safe tracking
okay we've used this method also for
um for doing something this is sort of
stepping now into learning methods
for planning robot motions when there's
quite an unpredictable environment and
as i said earlier one of the most
unpredictable parts of the environment
are the people in it
so here is a work that we've been doing
in conjunction with anka dragon's group
in eecs at berkeley and
this this work is assuming
that the people in the environment so in
this again stylized diagram
we have a quadrotor that's kind of
observing what the person's doing and
trying to plan a path that must avoid
the person and the trajectory that the
person's taking
um this is a a model that's used a lot
in the robot motion community
when um you're trying to plan robot
motions around people
and it's a a model of a person so this
is the
the quadrotor has this model of a person
represented by this
probability distribution or belief
distribution of where the person is
going to be
what action that human the action of the
human the input of the human
will take and the model is it's
basically a boltzmann
distribution model which in your beta is
that
inverse temperature coefficient of the
boltzmann distribution
and it's a model that says you know if
we model the person as goal driven
like for example this person may want to
get to the door
um and we can model those goals ahead of
time then the actions that the person
take must be generally optimal
towards the goal okay so this is the
this is the model and and when we talk
about optimality towards goal
it's um it it allows for some noisily
rational model that the person is
generally
moving towards their goals but there may
be some noise associated to it
okay so that's that's the model and it's
been used in robotics um
it's been used in cognitive science as
well as sort of a decision theoretic
model
so for example in this scenario the pink
region
would represent the regions of high
probability that the person is going to
move in because if they
want to move towards the door modeled by
this parameter theta
and then the blue regions would
represent regions of low probability if
the humans moving towards the door
they're probably not going to veer off
the straight line path
so so we we thought we'd use this with
one
caveat this parameter beta is something
that we can tune
it's a scalar and um and as the
the robot is gathering information about
its environment about what the person's
doing through maybe its cameras or its
vision system
then it could update that parameter
based on whether the person is being
more rational towards the moving towards
the goal that would correspond to a
higher value of beta
or less rational so if theta were zero
for example
this model is just a uniform
distribution over all possible actions
of the human a human could sort of move
in any direction
and so we implemented this using um fast
track for the robot motion
all right so here's the scenario where
the person turns around and maybe
they've forgotten their keys or
something
but the robot doesn't have that modeled
so it the
idea would be to update this parameter
beta
and we update it according to this uh
this this bayesian update that says okay
well
the person is not rational towards the
model anymore let's update beta
and so immediately the distribution of
where the person could become
spreads out so we tried this out with
fast track and so here you'll see some
movies
this is sylvia she's our human being and
sylvia herbert one of the researchers on
this project
the other people are andrea baichi jaime
fizzak david fridovich kyle and sylvia
and and there's a quadrotor this little
quadrotor that's just crashed into
sylvia
um is is here so the quadrotor sylvia is
trying to move across the room to the
door
um but there's a coffee spill here on
the floor it's not a real coffee spill
we've just marked it out but we put a
little cup there to indicate it's a
coffee spill
and um and the robot can see sylvia's
motion
but the robot doesn't know about the
coffee spill so the robot thinks that a
rational model of silvia would be to
move straight towards the door
and then as she moves the um the
the robot can basically you know update
her rationality or actually what is you
know we
call now model confidence it's our
confidence in our model
on what sylvia is going to do so let's
play this video
okay so um here sylvia is standing at
her initial position
and she starts to move what you see
these these sets emanating out of sylvia
are just the next few steps according to
this boltzmann
model and this quadrotor sees
you know you can see a top-down view of
the on the right of that same experiment
as sylvia starts to deviate the
robot becomes less sure of what sylvia's
going to do
and immediately the distribution around
her
starts to increase because the the robot
updates beta to a lower value to
indicate her uncertainty
okay we've extended this and let me just
show this video quickly
it scales so it scales to multiple
humans multiple robots there's two
quadrotors now that's sylvia and jaime
jaime's being a little irrational from
the beginning according to the model
because he's kind of moving slowly and
dancing a little bit
but what's interesting here is that that
that model that boltzmann model
naturally takes into account the fact
that when they come close together they
kind of stop and avoid each other
then the robot observes that and as
beta is automatically updated to be a
little more irrational because they're
each not moving towards their goal
there becomes a larger region for the
robot that's running this fast track
algorithm with reachability to avoid
okay so this is kind of a demonstration
of how you might use this
reachable set methodology with a
combined
um uh model of the environment
in order to end and a a single parameter
update so kind of moving towards
learning but not really learning yet to
do real-time motion planning
okay um and uh just to say that uh
andrea baichi has now taken these ideas
and and gone
a few more steps further with other
students in the lab samuel bonsal and
ellis ratner
to think about how one might actually
use reachability to analyze
things like the the dynamics of that
belief propagation
so could we instead of doing a simple
single parameter update
could we actually use reachable sets to
compute things like
what is the worst time to achieve a high
confidence in the model
so now the dynamics that we're
performing reachable
uh set computations on are not just the
human motion
they're our belief in our model of the
human motion
which i think is very exciting and new
so we have um 10 more minutes and i'd
like to finish a little bit early to
allow some time for questions
so in the last five minutes i'm going to
say one more word about high dimensional
sets using machine learning
and then just show you some of the
results that we've achieved over the
past few years
in incorporating machine learning into
these sets so these are more
example driven than they are then they
will be sort of the methodology
but what we've talked about so far is
introducing this concept of reachability
and um and designing methods which allow
you to incorporate
data in real time through some simple
um well not so simple but through
parameter updates on distributions
and how you might use that in real-time
motion planning
computing high-dimensional stats uh
reachable sets is still
you know very challenging and um and
we've contributed to some of this
literature but the latest thing we're
doing
and this is a this is just hot off the
presses it's a new uh result that samuel
bonsal
has just been achieving over this past
summer is to use
deep neural nets to actually do that
hamilton jacobi
calculation so you teach a neural
network how to solve a partial
differential equation
and i think it's just wonderful we've
now computer samuel has now computed
a nine dimensional reachable set without
i mean the only approximation comes in
now in the fact the approximation that
comes from the fact that you're using
a trained neural net to solve that
hamilton jacobi equation
and what's more we've been able to show
that
you know the in this light purple region
this is a
three aircraft encounter so three times
three-dimensional models is a
nine-dimensional set
we've never been able to compute that
directly before i mean these
these hamilton jacobi grid based methods
go up to about you know five or six
dimensions if you're lucky
otherwise you have to use all sorts of
decomposition methods that i talked
about earlier
but now he's computed an approximation
to the nine-dimensional set
and he's shown that it captures states
that are unsafe that we haven't been
able to capture before
so for example this red dot on the left
hand side
in these light purple states this is a
projection of this nine dimensional set
actually represents full um
this is a three aircraft conflict
that indicates that there is a loss of
separation between the three aircraft so
we're quite excited about this and
moving this forward
okay um learning dynamic behavior safely
so i'm i'm gonna
end with um just maybe two videos
two um experiments that we've done in
recent years
to show you know how one might
incorporate learning if you don't know
the dynamics or you know
some of the dynamics but not all of them
or you don't know the environment
or you don't know the um the constraints
on the system because you don't know the
dynamics
so let's end with that and so this is
the first uh
example in that realm this is the idea
that
we have um you know we have a model of
this quadrotor
and it's we're trying to make it go up
and down step trajectory up and down
um inside the room but we um in in terms
of safety here we want to make sure it
stays within an envelope so that it
doesn't you know fly
up too fast and hit the ceiling or come
down too fast and hit the floor
so we call this envelope protection and
we we have a model for the vehicle
and we compute the envelope given the
constraints of the ceiling and floor and
our knowledge of the limits on the
velocity we compute that envelope
and then in this experiment we took the
model away from the vehicle and we asked
it to learn a control law
okay so the quadrotor first drops to the
ground because it doesn't have a model
of itself so it doesn't have a control
but it it doesn't hit the ground we we
let it keep the reachable set that we
computed originally we just
don't give it its model and we used a
very simple
very simple learning scheme which is
called policy gradient sine derivative
here
inside that envelope so as it hits the
bottom of the envelope and it starts you
know applying a little bit of thrust it
it realizes that by applying thrust
it can move up it knows it can move up
so
it knows it wants to track this um
as best it can so that's the learning
but
what's constraining the learning is a
safety envelope
which is based on a nominal dynamic
model of the system
okay so it's a bit of an artificial
example because we took the model away
and and we asked it to learn it but but
it's sort of an example that shows
a first step in incorporating machine
learning into these tools
and um and what we've been doing over
the past few years
is to ask and let me just skip these um
is to ask okay well what if you um what
if you do learn a better model and you
you know you can start doing this can we
can we actually learn um constraints
as they're updated so what if something
comes into our environment
that we have to perceive and then you
know protect ourselves against
and this is a first experiment that we
did in that regard and i think this will
be my last um
my uh my last sort of piece that i'll
talk about before i skip to my
conclusions
so here in the second experiment of safe
learning
we have again a safe uh we have a
quadrotor it's still trying to fly that
up and down trajectory so it's still
trying to protect its envelope and not
hit the ceiling or floor
but there's a disturbance there's a big
fan in the room that is not
incorporated in the original nominal
model of the quadrotor
and so let's let's just see what happens
we've run
two experiments of this and then we've
superimposed them on top of each other
there's kenne akamatalu who was one of
the key authors of this work with jaime
fizzak
so he turns on the fan and the
quadrature comes down and now you'll see
the sort of separation between the two
different experiments
as the as the quadrotor hits the wind
field
there's there's two different quadrotors
reflecting these two different
experiments
so the ghosted out quadrotor is the one
that's not
scaling back its safety envelope based
on the disturbances that it's measuring
in real time
and it's not until it starts moving up
away from
the um the the wind vector field
that the two aircraft the two
experiments start to converge again
so it this this methodology
is basically updating the reachable set
to a level set of that a different level
set of that function
for which you can guarantee safety based
on the current measure of the
disturbances
okay so so what we're doing now and i'm
going to end
on this is um is we're applying these
ideas and extending them
to how we might learn in unstructured
environments
and so we've been incorporating
computer vision into our control loops
and
using deep neural nets for the computer
vision part so we're doing robot
motion planning learning about the
environment as it goes
and we've wrapped a safety envelope
around that
so if the control based
on the vision algorithm is asking the
vehicle to do something that's unsafe
according to a constraint based model we
have of the system
then the um the that that action
is pruned away just like a standard
reachability problem
and so that's those are some of the
directions we're moving in now let me
just skip to the end
to the conclusion slide
and conclude okay so we've talked about
safety from reachability analysis
we talked a little bit about um the the
need for simplicity so a sense of
having a hybrid system model which
allows you to design a control system
the way people tend to think about
control systems in
in large scale systems and we've we've
talked a little bit near the end of the
talk about how to learn from new
information
so so you know open questions that we're
working on are if you're in a safety
critical scenario how do you decide
that you've learned enough so that you
can update
your reachable set or you can update
your control based on safety
um how do we even model unstructured
environments these are questions we're
working on now
um we didn't get to talk about the last
piece of the talk which was how we
develop
a control law in unstructured
environments by
supervising the training of the vision
convolutional neural net using optimal
control
but that's one of the pieces that we're
using there and we've been working on
other topics in this vein like risk
sensitive reachability using
um the the sivar value
instead of the the j of x t value that
we've been talking about throughout this
talk
okay and i'd like to conclude with
thanking um
many students and former students who've
contributed towards this work
and also to thank the funding agencies
who funded a lot of work
and thank you very much
thanks very much claire that was a
really fascinating talk
we don't have much time if if people
have
one or two quick questions they can use
the q a feature
i was actually interested in the um
the use of these fast planning models uh
in in approximating the dynamics to to
avoid the curse of dimensionality
i wonder if there are cases where
there's a similar role for the
disturbance
model um you know trading off this sort
of
i guess conservativeness versus
tractability of of computing these
reachable sets you mean for
um trying to um trying to represent a
disturbance model
um yeah that is an excellent question
and that's been
um one of the focus
of our one of the focus areas of our
research in the past few years because
that's been the part of the system
you know in those those last few videos
i showed it's that disturbance model
which we've been trying to learn
as you learn a better disturbance model
um
you can conceivably you know shrink your
you can become
less conservative about about
reachability
and so that was our first take could we
could we in fact
learn more about the disturbances going
on and you know
in those examples that i showed they
were quite well-behaved disturbances
they come in
to be able to prove safety you have to
you have to make assumptions like the
disturbance is lit
the the the vector field of the
differential equation describing the
system
in each discrete mode is lipschitz
continuous in the disturbance
but under that assumption we can update
the disturbance we used a gaussian
process model for the disturbance
and um and updated it so we could learn
more can
or we could learn less conservative
reachable sets
but i think you're asking a slightly
different question you're saying
could we provide a simpler
representation maybe some kind of
structured representation of the
disturbance
maybe with a few parameters that we
could learn to be able to quickly
update that model and get less
conservative reachable sets
and that's something that i think is
fascinating um and and you know how to
parametrize
how to define that structure um
is i think a research agenda in itself
for for these different types of
problems we're interested in
all right well thanks very much claire
we're we're out of time um but
uh fascinating talk you finished lots to
think about
thank you very much peter and thanks
everyone for attending
thank you